ウトゥチッターレ・サンドーティ
そこで三つで三つの原因で生まれる色がありまして
四つの原因で生まれる色があると言ってるんです
そこら辺はまあ説明はしなくてもいいと思います
次に出てくるのはナクトーチ・ルーパ
ラッカのルーパアイ・ナクトーチ・ジャヤンティ
無色 どんな原因でもなく生まれる色があるんだと
どんな原因もなく生まれるというのはちょっとおかしい話なんですけど
何にも頼ってなくなく生まれる色があるんだと
それは結局色じゃないんです
これはアニッ ラッカのルーパなんですね
それはパーリ語では覚えていますよ
ウパッチャヤ・サンタティ・ジャラタ・アニッチャターと四つあるんです
ウパチャヤっていうのは物質が現れる
サンタティというのは物質はいくらか現れてちょっと生き続く
ジャラタというのは物質は変化して老化する
アニッチャターというのは物質は消えていく
結局生まれて消えていくということなんです
結局無常ということなんです
だからものは生まれて消えていくという現象は別に何か原因になってるわけじゃないと言ってるんですね
それはカルマだからですよ
心からですよって言ってないんですね
これは論理的な問題と思いますけどね
別にこの あの 物事は変化するっていうことは当たり前であって
これはしょうがないもので
物事の変化には特別なまた原因は探してないんですね
どうせかの原則があるんだから
物事は変化する この変化自体
別な色で見ているんだから
そこがおかしいだけなんです
アビダンマでは 変化自体は別に存在するものではない
変化という物質はあるわけないんだから
そこら辺でこの古い人々のこの分析のやり方なんですね
もう分析はきめ細かくするんだけど
どこかですごくおおざっぱというか
いい加減というか まあ現代的な理論にはなかなか当てはめないんですね
きちんと物質説明してますよ
きちんと物質説明してほしいんですね
そこで物質はちゃんと説明して
物質の特色も別の物質として見ているんです
物質があって特色があるんだから
それでウパダヤ・ルーパと言うんですね
エシ色と そこら辺 そんなに我々の現代的な
あの 知識からいうと ちょっと理解しにくいところで
理解しにくいというよりは
現代的な知識ではそんなことやったらちょっとおかしいんです
このエシ色というたくさんありますけど
それは全部この色として扱っちゃいけないんです
でもアビダンマでは扱ってるんです
本当はアビダンマでも言ってるんです
色は四つなんですね チー・スミカー
四つまとめたところで
人の体見るとありとあらゆる働きがあるんですね
それを別々に色だと色だと言ってるんです
で 基本的な四つとまた出てくるのはこの原因に起因の働きなんで
感受性なんです それもまとめたらそこで九つになっちゃうし
じゃあとりあえずそれに性別作ることのエネルギーも入れちゃったら十種類になっちゃうし
それぐらい十分なんです
色は  二十八種類なくても
他のが まあもっととことん説明してあげようと思ってやってるところなんです
いわゆるこういうことなんですね
じゃあ色を説明しようと思ったところで
結局目的は生命って何ですかという説明だから
そこに行き着いちゃうんですね
だから科学的な色の分析になってない
現代科学的な現代合理的な分析になってないんですね
現代的合理的分析で言えば
色だったら色説明しなさいということになりますけど
またもう一つ問題アビダンマであって
アビダンマは別にこの哲学を喋るために喋ってる心理学
哲学じゃないんです これは瞑想する場合は役に立つことだけ考えてるんですね
煩悩をなくすために修行するときは役に立つことだけ考えて
その目的で書いてるんだから
まあ一般的にはそれほど通用しない
ちょっと直してみると
かなり立派な 大変な立派な膨大な哲学なんですけども
ものすごくきめ細かく手を加えないと現代哲学にはならないんです
これは修行者のための哲学なんです
そこら辺なんですね まあややこしく難しくなってるのは
まあ一応色はどうやって生まれますかということは
まあここら辺で終了します
ちょっと二 三分休んで
あの気に細かいところはまああまりあの今のうち知らなくてもいいし
後で理解できるでしょうと思うんですけど
これからルーパカラーパということを説明します
で カラーパっていうのは
まあ色の十と書いてます
いわゆるこの一つ一つこの塊として束みたいに
まああるもので別々にインディペンデント
独立してある一つの色が存在しないんです
[背景音] ということなんですね
例えば水を持ってきてくださいというと
やっぱり入れ物なしに水を持ってくることは不可能なんですね
だから水があるということは
どこかに入れ物の中にあるということなんです
紅茶飲みますと言ったら
私は飲みたいのは紅茶ですけど
水は飲みたくないんだと言っても
それは無理な話で 紅茶飲む人はやっぱり一緒に水も飲まなくちゃいけないんですね
水と紅茶 紅茶は離れることはできないんですね
そういうふうなことで
この物質は独立して存在しない
だから まずこの基本的な物質
パタリ アポ テジョ ワユ
地水火風 決して離れることがないんですね
いわゆるパタリ 地だけ
いわゆる質量 硬さだけが存在するわけじゃない
ないんですね それにアポのお互いに引き寄せるエネルギーと引き離すエネルギーと火のエネルギーが全部あって
一個出来上がっちゃうんです
で パタリアポテジョワヨチスイカフで
このパタリアポテジョワヨチスイカフが４つまとめていつでもあるんです
ですから もう離れることは絶対ないんだと
この４つ生まれたら そこにまた４つの特色が現れるんですね
それはワンナ ガンダ ラサ
オージャという４つなんですね
いわゆる地水火風が１つの１個の単位で
その中にワンナという色がありまして
ガンダという香りがありまして
ラサという味がありまして
オージャというこの滋養素と書いてますから
この交換できる可能性というものがありまして
でも ワンナガンダラサオジャという色とガンダは香ですね
香と味と滋養素という
この４つは別なものではないんです
実際にあるのは地水火風なんですね
地水火風まとまるところでこういう特色が現れますよと
ですから その８つは離れることはできないんです
どうしても パタリアポテジョワヨ
ワンナガンダラソジャというやつはもういつでも一緒なんです
ですから 物質の一番小さい単位見ても
そこに地水火風があって
ワンナガンダラサオジャあります
その８種類の色にアヴィニッボーガルーパと言うんです
アヴィニッボーガルーパと言うんですね
ですから この８種類を１つの名前でアヴィニッボーガルーパと言うんです
アヴィニッボーガの日本語は何でしたっけ
不分別色 不分別色という感じなんです
言葉なんですが 意味は私もわかりませんだけど
いわゆる離れること 別々にすることは不可能ですと
お茶といえば水を離れて
純粋に水を別にして お茶別にするということは不可能なんですから
お湯があってお茶ですから
そんな感じで離れることはできないと
アヴィニッボーガという
だから僕はこの前も説明しましたけど
例えばこの地水火風の場合はこのテジョ
火の元素あるんですね
じゃあ火は別にあるんじゃないかと
燃えている場合は それはただの純粋に火だけではないかと
いつも炎さえ地水火風なんですね
炎さえ地水火風 炎にも重さがあるんです
体に この手でこうやって触ってみると
ちゃんと体に触れるんです
もう火傷するのは別の話で
火傷する前に体にぶつかるのはわかるんですね
だからぶつかって感じるのは地の幻想なんですね
じゃあ阿婆は水ではないかと
水じゃないんです 水も地水火風なんです
水の場合は  水の幻想の方が量多いかもしれません
炎の場合は 火の幻想は量が多いかもしれません
それだけのことで すべての
だから素粒子一つ取っても
そちらに地水火風があるんです
地水火風という四つ種類のエネルギーがあるんです
地水火風の四種類の波動が入っちゃうと
エネルギーが入っちゃうと
そちらにワンナガンダラソウジャというものが出てくるんです
ですから 小さなものには我々には色を見えませんだけど
たくさん集まると見えてくるんですね
例えば絵の具があります
この粉状態の絵の具があるんだと
それでたくさんになると
これは赤いや青いかと言えますけど
ほんの一粒だけ取ってみると
我々わからない 赤か青かどっちかと
でも一番小さな粒にも赤か青かもあるんですね
そうでなくて なんでたくさん集めたら赤くなるんですかね
そういうことですから
一番最初の単位にも この色やら味やら全部入ってるんだと
地要素 例えば人間はご飯食べる場合は
必要なのはご飯の中にあるエネルギーかもしれませんだけど
ご飯全部地水火風として食べなくちゃいけないんです
そこで体に入るのも全部地水火風
全部入っちゃうんです
で なんでそれだったら地要素だけ言ってますかというと
それだったらどんな地水火風食べてもいいんじゃないかと
人間がどんなものを食べてもいいんじゃないかというと
そうじゃないんです ある地水火を
例えばこの 今私はこの缶ジュース
缶コーヒー飲んだんだけど
じゃあ缶そのものを食べたらどうですかと
缶食べても その缶の中にある地水火風は体に入らないんですね
でも缶の中にあったコーヒーの地水火風は体に入りやすい
ですから 重層の問題が考えてるんですね
それでこの この八種類を覚えておいてください
地水火風と色と香味 地要素という
その八種類は決して離れることできない一つ
ワンセット それで この新しい物質が生まれたというと
このセットごとに生まれるんです
物質は存在している時もこのセットでいるんです
消える時もセットで消えちゃうんです
[背景の物音]それで物質のこのセット論が出てくるんですね
色十という ルーパカラーパというカラーパ論が出てくるんです
セット セットで生まれてセットでいてセットで消えちゃうんですね
パックでワンパックで生まれたらそのパックはそのまま消えてしまいます
どれぐらいセットありますかと
二十一種類のセットを考えてるんですね
色のセット二十一種類あるんだと
そこで九つのセットがカルマから生まれている
六種類のセットが心から生まれている
で 自施設種は四つありまして
で 地要素からは二つ生まれるんだ
それで二十一なんですね
じゃあカルマから生まれるセットを説明します
業からどんな九つが生まれますかと
まずこのこの一つ考えましょう
チャックソータガーナジーハーカーエ
眼耳鼻舌身という一つ
目っていうのは見られるエネルギーなんですね
ものを認識できるエネルギー
それはチャックと呼ぶんですね
これは独立しないんです
それにこのアヴィンボーが八
今説明したこの離れることできない
不可分別の色が八種類あるんですね
不可分別の八っていうのは
地水火風と色声香味と地要素という八は不可分別
その不可分別の八と それにもう一つジーリテルーパというものがつけるんですね
ジーリテルーパ ジーリテルーパは何でしたっけ
名色 名色という まあ命という色なんですね
生きているという意味で
それが一つ立つんです
そうすると九つになるんですね
それにもう一つ立つんです
チャック それで十種類になるんです
十種類のセットになるんです
チャックというのは眼耳鼻舌身の眼という目というところ
だから目という見られるエネルギーに
命というエネルギーと八種類の不可分別色が付加されて十種類になります
その十種類で生まれて十種類も消えちゃうんです
十のセットで生まれて十のセットで消えちゃうんです
だからずっと我々の目の中で見られるエネルギー
見られる可能性 いわゆる見られる
何でしたっけ この感受性ですか
その見えるという感受性が
いつでも色が十種類のセットで生まれているんですね
十種類のセットで生まれて
十種類のセットでセットで消えてしまいますよ
パーリ語でチャックダサカと言うんですね
チャック 目 入っている
ダサカというのは十種類と
まあそんなに難しいことじゃないんです
まあ目の見られる力っていうのは別に取り出すことはできないんです
地水火風で取り出さなくちゃいけない
地水火風と一緒に取り出さなくちゃいけない
考えなくちゃいけないんです
まあ他の言葉で言うなれば
どこにでも地水火風と
火風があるんだけど あるところの地水火風に
そっと外の世界の形を認識できるんですね
いわゆる あの まあ光と言ってもいいし
光に反応するんですね
どんな地水火風も光に反応するわけじゃないんです
人間の場合は目ですから
目の中にほんのかすかな一部が光に反応する
でもそれは細胞には変わりはないんだ
普通の細胞であって 普通の DNA で出来上がっている
でも細胞 細胞で言ったっても
そのその細胞はまたまた違うし
骨の細胞は違うし 目の細胞はまた違うし
ですからそのちょっとのその違うところがここで考えてるだけ
ですから見えるということは
普通の細胞なんですけど
光に反応するって それはチャック・ダサカ
次に眼耳鼻舌身だから次に出てくるのは耳なんですね
そこも十種類なんですね
不還別の八と 命という一つと耳
それを同じ細胞なのに音に敏感
音に反応する それはソータ・ダサカと呼んで
チャック・ダサカ ソータ・ダサカ
これはチャック・ダサカ
次にソータ・ダサカ で
十種類 十種類 十のセット
十種類のセット そこで眼耳鼻舌身だから
五つのセットが出来上がっちゃうんです
チャックとガージュアカーヤですから
五つのセットが出来上がっちゃうんですね
それ まあもう五つのセットがありまして
次にバハヴァ・ダサカというものがあるんです
ダサカっていうのは十のセットっていうことです
バハヴァ バハヴァってこちらで書いているのはこの性識なんですね
男性識と女性識と 生命が男性か女性かという区別するエネルギーなんですね
それはどういうふうに出来上がっちゃいますかというと
この不還別の八と 名色という命という一つと
女性の場合は女性識一つと十
十種類ですね 男性の場合は不還別の八と
名色のいちと 男性識という一つと十種類になっちゃうんですね
そこでバハヴァ・ダサカは二つあるんですね
そのセット二つあるんですね
そこで七つのセットになりますね
次にあのワット・ダサカというセットが出てくるんです
ワット・ダタガ ワットっていうのは
あの この あの 心が基本としている
あの よりどころとしている物質なんですね
人間の心のエネルギーが
人間の心のエネルギーをよりどころにしている物質はどこにあるかはわからないと言ってましたから
もう体中あるかもしれませんし
それなんですね それはどういうふうなセットかというと
この不還別識の八と名色と心基
色ですね その十種類をまとめたら
そこでワット・ダタガという一つ生まれちゃうんですね
それで八種類 八種類のセットが生まれるんです
それから最後に この生きている体のことを言ってるんだから
体だけのことを考えると
この不還別識の八と それに名根だけ
名色 あ 名 ジーヴィタ・ルーパだけ
名だけ 名色だけつなげたら
九つが出てくるんですね
九つのセットが それはジーヴィタ・ナガと呼ぶんですね
名 それは一つのセットです
今まで十種類 十種類と言ったんだけど
最後に言っているセットには九つしかないんです
じゃあ 小さい科学と  色・香・味・受・想だけまとめたら
この不還別識の八だけ出来上がっちゃうんですね
名根も抜けちゃったら
それはただの物質なんですね
体に関係ないんです 体の物質と
この石やら土やら その物質に何か違うんですね
体っていうのは生きている物質で
石とか生きている物質じゃないんですね
だから何が違うかというと
このジーヴィタ・ルーパなんですね
名色なんです 命という物質的なエネルギーはないんですね
外には でも体の物質は全部
命というエネルギーが働いているんです
生きている物質なんです
体に義足とか あるいは心臓に何か
まあ人工 人工的な弁とかなんとか入れちゃったら
その部分は生きているものじゃないんです
でも移植なんかしちゃったら
そのものは生きているんですね
ですから 移植の場合は移植するものが生きてなきゃ
もう動かないんですね
生きていたっても それは本人の名色に入れ替えないと
他人の名色だけではダメなんです
人の心臓は移植する その死んだ人の
あの 名色が生きている間
取って持ってきて それを冷やしちゃって
この命は伸ばしてもらって
もうトランスプランティングあるいはまあ
なんて言いますか 忘れちゃったけど
英語が出てくると日本語忘れちゃう
移植 まあ移植しなくちゃいけないんですね
で 移植したところで その心臓の物質はずっと変化していくんだから
小さい科学の変化は大丈夫ですけど
栄養が与えられますけど
でもその体にこの心臓がつくかつかないかということは別の話で
拒絶されるかないかということで
そこで拒絶しなかったというならば
どんどん新しい物質が生まれると
名根識がその人の名根識になってるところで
もう同じものになっちゃうんです
それでも まああの 基本的なものは違いますから
小さい科学がいつ捨てられるかわからないんです
捨てられる可能性はそれでもあるんですね
ですから 移植手術はもうかなりの危険性はいつでもあるんです
その違う命だから その命にそれは寄付される可能性はある
命の働きはそんなにも関係ない場合は
例えば あの 授血ですか
血液とか入れたりするのは簡単なんですね
血液入れる場合は お医者さん考えているのは
これは大変大事な部分ということではなくて
まあただ あの 物質だけなんですね
血液は足らないんだから入れてあげようと
だからそれは水を入れることと同じなんです
人が体の中の水分なくなっちゃったら
水を飲む それを吸収する
それと同じことですから
あの 授血で人は死ぬということは
まあよほどお医者さんが混乱してない限りはないんですね
でも体の組織の場合はそうじゃないんで
組織自体は生きてなきゃいけませんし
この骨髄移植の場合も
この骨髄の型が合わなきゃいけないというのはそういうことで
型が合うということは物質的にはぴったしなんですね
C3カフの構想としてはぴったしで
そこら辺はすごくうまくつなげちゃう
次に必要なのは そのものはその人の心が受けてるかないかっていうことだけ
だからここほとんどの条件揃ってるんだから
心にそれ拒否しない する必要なくなっちゃうんですね
それでだんだん骨髄が受け取ってしまっちゃう
受け取っちゃったらもうどんどん復元して作って
新しいものを作って 作って
その血 白血病 病気とか
そういうのは消えちゃいますけど
だからそういう仏教のアビダンマ的なことを教えなくたって
ごく普通の知識でやってるのも同じことなんです
そこでこの心臓が消えちゃう
機能しなくなっちゃったら
全く人工的な心臓でもその働きはできるんですね
全くの機械で作った心臓ででも
でもその時はそこに それはあくまでも物体であって
機械であって 体の命の中にはならないんですね
精神的にすごくショック受けるんだ
ああだこうだくだらないことを言ってますけど
この移植しちゃったら
あれはまあくだらない妄想概念から生まれるかもです
移植して健康だったら
それで健康は その人の人格は変わるわけはないんです
殺人した人は人の心臓を移植したんだから殺人者になったとか
そういう映画とかありますけどね
そんなものは全くこの
そういう一般の人々のこの魂の概念とか
そういう実体論から生まれる何のことなくくだらない概念
ですから 我々の目が見えなくなっちゃったら
他の人のなんとか移植して目が見えるようになったっても
それは構いませんし 心臓が動かなくなっちゃったら
もう適当に心臓がもらったらそれは入れてもらってもそれは構いません
でも 人のカルマによって
人の心のエネルギーによって
それは受け取るか拒否するかっていうのは
それはまた別の話で 受け取ってなれば
これは人の心臓でなくなっちゃう
それは自分の心臓なんです
ですから この移植手術にある
この何の根拠もない この何て言いますか
緊張感というか この それは何も意味がないんです
日本でももう全然この提供しないんですね
もう亡くなってる人々の体の組織っていうのは
すっごいもう反対するんですね
ですから 人は死んじゃったら
まあ全部片っ端から取れるものは全部取らせてあげた方が尊いことだと思います
ただの部品ですからね
あげませんよ それで生きている連中考えてるんだから
それすごい原始的で もう全然知識的な考え方じゃないんです
人は死んじゃったんだから
そちらはもう冥婚はないんです
心もないし ただの物体なんですね
物体を見て おじいさんだ
お母さんだとかね 似てるだけだから
それはこの土で粘土で作ったって同じことだから
写真見てもお母さんに見えるでしょうに
写真自体はお母さんじゃないでしょうし
写真撮ったら魂は抜けちゃいますよという
このいろんなこの未開発のこの不足とか考え方あるでしょ
日本でも三人一緒にやって写真撮らないとかね
よくそういうことを人間というのは
この嘘だったらものすごい真面目に信じるんですね
で 真実だったら馬鹿にするんですね
だからそういう人間の生き方ですね
だから人間にすごく信頼
僕はすごく この  なんて言いますか
嫌味としての概念なんですけど
人間に大変人気あって
受けてほしいならばとことん嘘を言えと
絶対間違ってでも本当のことを言うなと
真実を語るな 真実を語ると大衆からもう離れちゃう
追い出されちゃうんですね
あんたおかしいんだと
嘘を言ってるんだ だから人気あればあるほど
みんなに売れていればいるほど
その分もうほとんどもう意味のない空っぽなものなんです
だから まあそんな世界ですから
世の中のこの割とあらゆる概念いっぱいあるんだけど
頑固で守ってる概念というならば
もうほとんどもう何の根拠もない
もうインチキ的な話 嘘の話なんです
お祝いですか それを拝んだり
まあお母さん おじいさん
ああだこうだとかね 泣いたり笑ったりしながら
もうご飯食べさせたりとか
いろいろやってますけど
酒飲ませたりとか それを大変大事な文化だとかって言いながら
よくまあ恥ずかしがらないで
そういうことはもう平気でやるんです
それにちょっとでも何か一言言っちゃったら
もうすごいんですね 反応が
だからまあ 私も人の心の調子を見て
まあこれは素晴らしいことだ
素晴らしいことだと思っちゃうんです
で ちゃんと物事を考える人だったら
ちゃんとのことを言っています
ですから 大体もうちゃんと真理を僕の方で知りたければ
子供には教えてあげるんです
危険だと とっとと身を護るんです
これは真実 これは冗長じゃないんだ
大人には言わないんですね
なぜなら大人っていうのは
それなりに社会的な力を持ってるんだから
どうするかわからないんです
ですから 様子を見て喋るんです
昨日もちょっと電話があって
電話がかかってきた瞬間で
あ 今日この場合はすごくとことん気をつけなくちゃいけないと思ったんです
いわゆる気を付けるっていうのは
真実は語らないんだと
まあごまかしておだててもう終わりにしますと
で まあみんな知ってる人ですから
誰かちょっと言いにくいんだけど
で まあすごく知識的にああだこうだとか
まあ喋って ああいいことでしょう
それはそれで まあこうすれば私はこうなるでしょうと思いますよと
ああ それはまあまさにその通りですよと
というのは 私の頭の中で
なんてアホかと で まあやっぱりどんどん話を長引いていっちゃうと
向こうもどんどん自分の立場の自分がこの考え方でこれやるつもりですよと言ってくれるんだから
そこはどんどん弱くなってくるんですね
向こうは 弱くなってくると
我でもさっさっと忘れちゃって
まあまあ 実はまあこういうことで
こういうまあ適当なことではないかとか
もう言い始めたんですね
それで時計見たらやっぱり時間も経ってるし
我々はもうどんどん自分の意見を言ってるように言ってるんですね
そこでまあ時間になっちゃったんだから
まあいいでしょうと すぐ電話切ったんです
とにかく まあ本当のことを
言える前に早くも電話終わったんです
やっぱりまあ大人の世界っていうのはそういう世界で
ですから 私は毎日神様にお祈りして
大変心はなごやかになりますよ
清々しい気持ちになりますよと
それはまあ どうでしょうかと僕に聞いたっても
僕は本当のことを言わない
そういう決まり 決まりつけてるんだから
それだったら それは大変いいことではないか
どうせ結果がいいんだからいいんじゃないかと
そこで終わっちゃうんですね
それだけの話になりますけど
まあまあ一応お釈迦様から見ても
真実だからといって片っ端からもう言いふらすものでもないんです
人間は理解するかしないか
混乱を起こすかないかということも
やっぱり人々の気持ちも考えなくちゃいけないんですね
いくらむちゃくちゃ馬鹿なことをやっていたとしても
それは直せたところで
社会システムまで壊されて大変なことになっちゃうと
もう良くないんですね
例えば日本でこの伝統的なお祭りあるでしょ
もう智慧の目で見ると
あれほど馬鹿げたことっていうのは見ていられないほど馬鹿げたものなんですね
喧嘩祭りやらもうああだこうだとか
裸祭りと 何やってるんですかね
でもかえってだからと言って
そんなものに片っ端から批判しちゃうと
人間の生き方自体はもうちゃんとみんな調和して
平和で お互いに助け合って気持ちよく生きてる
このシステム自体が壊れてしまいますから
まあそこら辺でいいとこだけ見て
いいでしょう みんなまとめて村人をみんな
町の人々をみんなまとめて
大変気持ちよく 楽しく
仲良くお祭りするんだから
それは大変素晴らしいんだぐらいは言ってあげる
その分は嘘ではないんだから
そこでまたもうノリに乗っちゃって
こういうお神輿をやってると
本当に神様が見えてくるんだとかね
というと やっぱりそれでちょっと一言付け加えたり